H Hélènene Buzzetti, Chantal Ht
etet Alec Castonguay, bonsoir.
CeCes images de calme, je pense
ququ'on va la remettre, ça nous
fafait du bien après s une fin e
sesemaine agitée la semaine
dedernièrere. Je l'ai dit d'ente
dede jeu à l l'émission, j'ai sé
nonos collègugues qui ont été se
teterrain. Il faisait froid en
plplus. Tout étant calme, est-ce
ququ'on a encore besoin de cette
loloi? Tour de table et après se
vovous fais entendre des extrai.
- - On se retrouve dans une
sisituation bancale parce que le
vovote sur cette loi a lieu ce
sosoir, exactement une semaine
apaprès s son évocation.
DoDonc, les députés le voient
cocomme un vote pour pérenniseru
prprolonger l'application de la
loloi, alors qu'en fait, il faut
ququand mêmeme le voir comme unl
ququ'on donne ou qu'on ne donne
papas au fait d'avoir utilisé la
loloi. C'est ce qui explique le
fafait que le gouvernement décle
quque c'est un vote de confianc,
dudu bout des lèvrvres, mais qud
mmêmeme. Si ce vote devrait ne s
papasser, ça créerait une
sisituation particulièrere où le
gogouvernement n'aurait pas eu a
coconfiance d'avoir fait ce qu'l
a a déjà f fait.
CÇa ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
pepeut pas arrêteter la loi dans
cicinq jours.
- - C'est très s intéressant, ce
nunuance. C'est un vote sur le
papassé de la dernièrere semain.
MoMonsieur Lametti vient de le
didire, d'ici la fin de la
sesemaine, c'est possible qu'ona
reretire.
- - Totalement d'accord avec
HéHélènene. Ce vote est fait por
vavalider ce que le gouvernemena
dédécidé de faire, invoquer la
loloi. D'autre part, il sert à
prprotéger aussi le gouvernement
dudu Canada contre des
cocontestations juridiques. Il a
y y en avoir, sur sa décision
d'd'avoir eu recours à l la loir
leles mesures d'urgence.
ImImaginer que le gouvernement,
pependant une semaine, a fait ce
ququ'il a fait et qu'il n'obtiet
papas l'aval du gouvernement oue
lala Chambre des communes,
çaça affaiblit nettement sa caue
enen cour. L'idée qu'on dise du
bout des lèvrvres que c'est un
vovote de confiance, je pense qe
c'c'est incontournable que c'est
unun vote de confiance. Si la
ChChambre des communes n'a p pae
coconfiance en majorité sur Jusn
TrTrudeau sur cette loi, c'est
didifficile de dire qu'il y a
enencore de la confiance à l l'd
dudu gouvernement minoritaire.
- - Monsieur Lametti a dit que
c'c'est pour les libéraux...
- - Il y aurait pu y avoir un ou
dedeux député libéraux plus
scsceptiques, mais je ne pense s
quque les libéraux auraient voté
dudu côtété du gouvernement. Les
cocorps policiers l'ont dit, ele
a a été utile la semaine derniè.
ElElle a aidé à d dissuader la
popoursuite de certains barrage.
ElElle a été utile la semaine
dedernièrere. On l'entérine
auaujourd'hui, ça me semble dans
l'l'ordre des choses. Est-ce qun
dedevrait la maintenir 30 jours?
CÇa me semble beaucoup. On ne
pepeut pas à t titre préventif r
cece type de loi en place.
DaDavid Lametti-la un peu évoqu,
çaça pourrait êtrtre quelque jo.
- - Si on lit le sou texte, à la
fifin de la semaine, s'il n'y a
ririen de nouveau qui arrive...
- - On aurait pu télégraphier un
pepeu plus clairement aujourd'h,
mamais je ne pense pas qu'on va
mamaintenir ça de manièrere
prprolongée. N'est pourtant érié
lala dernièrere semaine, ça me
sesemble évident.
- - On va entendre des extraitse
M.M. Trudeau et de M. Singh, qui
vava voter pour.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU, premier minise
dudu Canada
- - Mais on sent encore que,
ceces jours-ci, dans le moment
prprésent, la situation est ence
frfragile. La situation d'urgene
esest encore présente.
N Nous allons continuer de
susurveiller au jour le jour por
vovoir quand est-ce qu'on pourra
lele lever, ce sera pas pour
l'l'immédiat, mais à t tous les
jojours on va réévaluer et on
l'l'espèrere ne pas le garder ue
jojournée de plus que nécessair.
JAJAGMEET SINGH, chef,
NoNouveau Parti démocratique
- - Notre appui pour ce vote
esest avec réticence. Et on va
cocontinuer de dire ce que j'ai
didit. J'ai avisé le gouverneme,
j'j'ai avisé le premier ministre
quque notre appui ne va pas
cocontinuer pour une longue dur,
popour 30 jours, qu'on est prêtt
d'd'enlever notre appui, si jams
c'c'est le cas qu'on ne pense ps
quque c'est nécessaire
dede continuer d'appuyer.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Alors, le premier ministre
ajajoute une contrainte à u une
cocontrainte. Il invoque la loi
lala plus contraignante de
l'l'arsenal juridique, et parce
ququ'il a peur de se planter, il
memenace d'imposer la contraint,
d'd'en faire un vote de confian.
C'C'est un constat d'échec
etet ce n'est certainement pas
unune preuve de courage.
- - Je vais vous montrer un
tatableau. Il y a eu 219 comptes
babancaires gelés. C'est beaucop
lala loi. Les véhicules remorqu,
çaça a été plus facile avec la
loloi. Et les arrestations et
acaccusations, ça a un peu rienà
vovoir. C'est le bilan de
l'l'opération. Vous l'avait dit,
leles policiers ont dit depuis
jejeudi : ça nous est utile, çaa
fafacilité la coordination.
HéHélènene, un mot sur cette
opopération policièrere qui a éé
lalancée vendredi matin.
- - Vous l'avait dit tout à
l'l'heure dans votre entrevue ac
MoMonsieur Lametti, ce n'est pas
unun peu le propre aux policiers
dede demander plus de moyens, ps
d'd'outils? Et c'est un bon poi.
MaMais en mêmeme temps, c'est ai
unune réalité ou un constat qu'n
dodoit poser 14 ou à r raison, s
auautorités en place estimée ne
papas avoir d'outils suffisants
popour intervenir dans cette
ococcupation. On ne peut quand
mmêmeme pas nier que cette loi a
étété efficace. Les gels bancais
enen particulier semble avoir éé
unun incitatif assez puissant.
QuQuand tout d'un coup, vous
n'n'avez plus accès s à v votree
dede guichet pour aller acheteru
cacafé pour vous réchauffer, çaa
unun effet très s certain. Et un
pepetit mot aussi, le maire Watn
ququi proposait qu'on revende ls
cacamions qui ont été saisis por
papayer les frais, le gouvernemt
nene peut pas dire si ces permi,
mamais je pense qu'il a remisé
cecette idée. Ils ont tweeté
auaujourd'hui que les camions
seseront gardés à l la fourrière
sesept jours et ensuite, les ges
popourront les récupérer. Souve,
ceces camions valent dans les sx
chchiffres.
- - Sur l'opération policièrerer
lala façon dont ça a procédé,
ququ'est-ce que vous en dites?
- - Ça a procédé comme une
opopération policièrere devrait
poposséder, comme elle a procédà
QuQuébec, au pont Ambassadeur. e
pepense
quque le message du gouvernement
auaux forces de police et :
ororganisez-vous pour êtrtre pra
prprochaine fois parce qu'on nea
papas garder ces mesures en plae
pependant une journée de plus qe
cece qu'on a besoin de le faire.
EtEt Jagmeet Singh qui dit : one
sesera pas d'accord pour 30 jou.
EnEntendons-nous, il suffit que0
dédéputés demandent qu'on vote e
momotion pour évoquer la loi por
quque dans les trois jours, on
dodoive en débattre dans une
chchambre ou l'autre.
AÀ partir du moment où le débat
cocommence, il y a 10 heures por
sese conclure et il y a un vote.
CeCe n'est pas comme si le
gogouvernement avait une espècee
babail qu'il pouvait renouvelerà
vovolonté. On sent que ça ne
popourra pas durer.
JeJe me dis qu'il doit y avoir e
cecertaine nervosité dans les
rarangs, mêmeme si les partisano
dédémocrates disent qu'ils sont
d'd'accord. Quand on est sorti
auaujourd'hui pour défendre la
poposition du NPD, c'est
gégénéralement parce qu'on a
bebesoin de l'appui.
- - Sur la durée, je pense que s
gegens auront compris qu'ils
n'n'auront pas le choix. Je
rereviens sur l'opération qui a
étété chorégraphiée. Ça a été
tetellement lente au début, on a
lalaissé les gens s'installer.
EnEn fin de semaine, ça a été ue
opopération policièrere qui a ré
rorondement.
- - On a découvert beaucoup de
mamanifestations dans un autre
tetemps. Je n'étais pas à c celi
àà O Ottawa, mais on l'a tous
reregardés pas mal. Beaucoup de
nonos collègugues étaient sur p.
JeJe ne me souviens pas d'une
opopération d'aussi grande en,ùu
ilil y a eu assez peu
d'd'escarmouches. En général,
ququ'on est procédé assez peu
d'd'arrestations... Au G20 à
ToToronto, 1000 arrestations. On
n'n'a pas fait de souricièrere,n
n'n'a pas essayé de coincer les
mamanifestants. On les a laissé
sosortir comme il voulait.
AvAvec cet accord policier
didifférent, qui ne travaille ps
totoujours de la mêmeme manièren
a a réussi à p procédé comme ça,
avavec un relatif calme. C'était
lele noyau le plus radical qu'il
rerestait dans la ville.
PoPour ceux qui connaissent sa
plplus que moi, on dit que c'est
prpresque un manuel d'instructin
ququ'on devrait enseigner dans s
écécoles de police sur le contre
dedes foules. Ce n'est jamais
paparfait, mais en général, c'et
prprobablement ce qu'il pouvait
ararriver de mieux.
- - Ça a été beaucoup souligné,
papar les gens sur place.
ChChorégraphiée au quart de tou.
OnOn voit beaucoup les chevaux.
IlIl y a eu une fausse inforormn
ququi est sortie, quelqu'un aurt
étété mort et ce n'est pas vrai.
MaMais quelqu'un a été blessé,
alalors il y aura une enquêteter
cecet épisode des chevaux.
L'L'Ukraine, Monsieur Poutine qi
esest allé d'un discours enflam,
ququi a sorti toutes ces
rérécriminations face au passé,à
l'l'URSS qui a laissé tomber
ininjustement les républiques
sosoviétiques un après s les aus
sasans dédommagement. Et l'Ukrae
enen particulier, il dit que ce
n'n'est pas un vrai pays, que
c'c'est une colonie américaine.
CeCes étais le président d'un
pepetit pays, on dirait, bon ça
vava. Mais c'est quand mêmeme
MoMonsieur Poutine.
LeLes deux républiques prorusse,
ilil y a une partie qui seront
vrvraisemblablement annexés.
PoPoutine les a reconnus
inindépendantes.
- - J'ai aucune idée de commente
gogouvernement canadien espèrere
apapprocher ça, mais espérons qe
çaça sera peut-êtrtre différent
ququ'avec la Crimée. On a
l'l'impression avec Monsieur
PoPoutine qu'on a déjà j joué ds
lele mêmeme film, avec la Crimét
lala Géorgie. Il y a toujours
cecette mêmeme procédure, j'appe
çaça une partition extérieure.
IlIl procèdede au morcellement u
teterritoire qu'il veut
rereconquérir. Jusqu'à p présene
CaCanada s'était montré assez
didiscret. On sent une crainte e
sese mettre le coût t sur le bi,
d'd'avoir l'air trop différent
popour nos alliés. On emboîtete
coconstamment le pas de nos alls
prprincipalement américains.
J'J'imagine que ce sera la mêmee
chchose, mais devant une telle
hahausse de ton, il va falloir e
lele Canada LAR à l la hauteur e
cecette hausse de ton.
- - M. Biden qui a signé un
dédécret. On voit qu'il est un u
imimpuissant. On va couper tout
lilien avec ces deux république.
QuQue faire devant un homme come
cecelui-là??
- - La balle est dans le camp de
l'l'union européenne. Ce n'est s
lele Canada qui est en premièree
liligne. Et oui, le président
amaméricain. C'est un peu l'aver
dede l'Europe qui se joue, pas
seseulement de l'Ukraine, mais
auaussi de la Lettonie...
CeCe n'est néanmoins pas le Cana
ququi va dire à l la France et à
l'l'Allemagne et à l la Grande-
BrBretagne comment défendre leus
inintérêtsts en territoire euro.
OnOn a déjà v vu que le temps du
CaCanada avait monté un peu.
OnOn a accepté de vendre des ars
lélétales à l l'Ukraine. Il y au
unune montée d'un cran.
MaMais le Canada n'agira pas
ununilatéralement, il va agir ss
leles auspices de l'OTAN. Un jo,
c'c'est la question va se poser,
esest-ce qu'on contribue avec ds
trououpes s'il y a une contre-
ofoffensive militaire?
- - Le Canada ne joue aucun rôle
imimportant dans cette crise.
OnOn n'est pas un jour importan.
ChChantal et LN ont raison.
L'L'union européenne est vraimet
auau coeur de cette joute
didiplomatique. On hésite entre
sosoulagement et inquiétude
auaujourd'hui. Soulagement danse
sesens où pour ne pas perdre la
faface, c'est ce que Vladimir
PoPoutine souhaitait, annexés cs
dedeux républiques, qui sont déà
papas mal indépendantes, du
teterritoire ukrainien. De pouvr
didire : je range les armes et n
dédésescalade. Il y a aura un ds
réréactions des pays occidentau.
OuOu est-ce que ça a quelque che
dede plus agressif, marcher sur
KiKiev, l'invasion de l'Ukraine
ququ'on craint depuis des
sesemaines. On ne laissait pas t
àà p peu près s personne ne lai.
MMêmeme dans l'entourage de
Vladimir Poutine, je ne suis pas
cecertain qu'on s'est où il veut
enen arriver avec cette pression
ququ'il exerce sur les pays
ococcidentaux. Les prochaines
heheures vont êtrtre critiques.-
cece qu'on arrêtete la on s'en t
àà c ce statu quo? Et Vladimir
PoPoutine va pouvoir dire qu'ila
fafait quelque chose pour ses as
prprorusses. Ou est-ce qu'il
popousse plus loin? On aura
jojournée assez intense d'ici la
fifin de la semaine.
- - Est-ce que c'est la porte de
sosortie pour Poutine face aux
RuRusses? Ou ce n'est pas la poe
d'd'entrée plus large? Ça va
dédépendre aussi de la réactione
l'l'Ukraine. Est-ce que l'Ukraie
vava dire : très s bien, détach-
vovous? Où il n'y aura pas de vi
cocombat? S'il y à d des vrai
cocombat, c'est une invitation à
VlVladimir Poutine.
- - Ça dépend comment on voit le
plplus tard. On avait un peu dit
lala mêmeme chose avec la Crimé.
OnOn peut circonscrire le
prproblèmeme. On a l'impressione
MoMonsieur Poutine a une visionà
trtrès s long terme et que son s
tatard peut êtrtre quelques anns
plplus tard, mais il avance
totoujours un peu plus.
CeCette considération qu'il faut
gagarder à l l'esprit.
- - Personne n'est éternelle, et
çaça inclut Vladimir Poutine.
DaDans la liste des moins, il ya
l'l'annonce de Vladimir Poutine,
ququi va envoyer des troupes de
mamaintiens de la paix dans ces
dedeux provinces. Je ne suis pas
coconvaincu que l'Ukraine peut
totolérer ou mêmeme la communaué
ininternationale puisse considér
çaça comme autre chose que de
cocommencer à s s'emparer d'une
papartie du territoire de
l'l'Ukraine.
- - On va suiv